good morning Hank it's Friday October
26th today I'm going to discuss the
political situation in Nepal while
eating five sheets of toilet paper our
story begins in 2001 Nepal is a
constitutional monarchy it's in the
middle of a lot of political crises the
biggest one of which is that there are
all of these Maoist rebels who are
trying to take over the country now I
know you're thinking Maoist rebels
Maoist rebels are the contemporary
insurgency what like Friendster is to
contemporary social networks
nobody has Maoist rebels anymore I mean
someone needs to phone Nepal tell them
that it's 2007 that they need to get
some like Islamic insurgents or some
small random ethnic group that wants
independence the countries in the middle
of this civil war with all these Maoist
rebels and the crown prince wants to
marry a girl now how was the girl that
the crown prince wants to marry is in
the wrong clan and so his parents are
opposed to this and so the crown prince
reacts the way you know with this sort
of like a calm thoughtful reaction that
you would expect from a crown prince
which is that he gets a machine gun and
proceeds to kill pretty much his entire
family he kills his mom he kills his dad
he kills a brother he kills a sister he
kills like two of his aunts and two of
his uncles I think he killed some
cousins and he then he shoots himself in
the head which is a little bit
suspicious but anyway when you're a
constitutional monarchy Hank you need a
king or a queen and the guy just killed
like pretty much the entire family right
so I got a problem hold on I got swallow
and then like is one of his uncle's who
didn't get shot somehow became king now
there's a long-standing theory that the
uncle might have in fact done the
shooting to become King although I
worked out being king of Nepal not that
great of a gig eventually 12,000 people
are killed in this civil war and then
finally in 2005 the King announces I am
going to be God there will be no more
constitutional monarchy he dissolves the
parliament but of course that's for like
really hard to do it doesn't go that
well
mock receipt protests in 2006 so
eventually the king brings back to
Parliament in late 2006 the Maoist
rebels and the Parliament kind of had a
talk and they agree no more fighting
then eventually a Maoist rebels come
into the government and take some seats
in parliament
there's relative peace even earlier this
year they said that there were gonna be
elections in June everyone's like yes
elections in June they were totally
psyched the king had become just a
figurehead King old ah I just swallowed
a lot of toilet paper all at once so
then at the last possible second base I
know no elections in June of 2007 we're
gonna have the elections in November of
2007 and then about a week ago Hank you
want they announced they announced that
they don't want to have elections after
all and the Maoist rebels having left
the government now are now threatening
to strike the civil war again so things
are very perilous right now what we need
is serious international intervention a
few days ago the Security Council
announced that they were really strongly
opposed to Nepal not having elections I
just swallowed my fifth piece of toilet
paper yes I am the toilet paper eating
king of the world
Hank it's a quick PS the first thing
that comes up when you google how to eat
toilet paper is a woman asking the
following question I just caught my
husband eating toilet paper question
mark I asked him why he was eating it
and when I asked him about it again he
said moisture reduces volume it's true
moisture does reduce of all here anyway
Hank if that woman happens to be a
nerdfighter it just so happens that I
dunno what's wrong with your husband he
has pica or Piko I don't know how you
pronounce it P Corp IKEA is a disease in
which you eat things that aren't food
it's a little bit weird but it's nothing
to be ashamed of I mean this stuff is
kind of delicious I'll see you on Monday